اذا راويه ينعقد مؤتمر المناخ كوب 27 في
شرم الشيخ المصريه في ظل ظروف عالميه
معقده سياسيا اقتصاديا وحتى مناخيا كانه
الارض على وقع انبعاثات الكربون المتزايده
والوعود بموقف دولي حاسم للتغيير وعود لم
تخرج من الورق الى الواقع منذ العام 2020
بقياده كبار الملوثين في العالم
تصدرت الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
قائمه المقصرين بالتمويل المناخي وتقديم
الحصه العادله التي تتناسب وحجم الضرر
المناخي الصادر من اراضيهم تقصير الكبار
في تعهداتهم كان محل لون الرئيس الفرنسيه
موجها سهاما انتقاده تحديدا الى امريكا
والصين فهما لم تخفضان بعثاتهما ولا
التزمت بتعهداتهما الماليه تعهدت الدول
الغنيه بتقديم
مليار دولار سنويا بحلول 20 20 لكن الهدف
لم يتحقق لكن من الذي تقاعس حصه الولايات
المتحده مثلا بناءا على انبعاثاتها
السابقه 40 مليار دولار لكنها قدمت 7.6
مليار دولار فقط في عام 2020 في المقابل
قدمت استراليا وكندا حول ثلث التمويل
المطلوب منهما بينما قدمت المملكه المتحده
ثلاثه ارباع التمويل لكنها لا تزال تتخلف
بمقدار مليار واربع مئه مليون دولار لانه
نتابع معكم اكثر مقدار العجز في التمويل
[موسيقى]
على الجهه الاخرى هناك من مول المناخ
باكثر من اضعاف قصته المفروضه سويسرا مثلا
قدمت اربعه اضعاف المبلغ بينما كانت تمويل
فرنسا والنرويج اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف
المبلغ اليابان ايضا هي واحده من اكبر
ممولين قدمت ال 13 مليار دولار اي اكثر من
ضعف المبلغ المطلوب منها لكن
وراء هذا السخاء تمويل اليابان وفرنسا كان
في معظمه على شكل قروض في حين كانت تمويل
من الولايات المتحده وكندا واستراليا
والمملكه المتحده في غالبيته كان من حمى
والطبع تفضل البلدان الناميه تفضل ذلك
بشده نتابع معكم مقدار قائد التمويل
المناخي لبعض الدول
[موسيقى]
يعول على مؤتمر كوب 27 بان تكون قضيه
تمويل المناخ حاسمه فيه لاحراز التقدم
المنشود تواجه البلدان ضعيفه حاله حياه او
موت واثقه صحيفه تجارديان البريطانيه
وتحتاج الى اكثر من 100 مليار دولار كان
الهدف من المئه مليار دولار تلك دعم خفض
انبعاثات الكربون والعمل على تكييف
المجتمعات مع الطقس القاسي المتزايد
الناتج عن الاحتباس الحراري ومع ذلك كشفت
سلسله من التقارير الاسبوع الماضي عن مدى
قرب الكوكب من كارثه المناخ مع عدم وجود
مسار موثوق لخفض الكربون الى درجه ونصف
مئويه وهو الحد الاقصى متفق عليه دوليا
لدرجه الحراره لتجنب السوء ازمه مناخيهرش
اون لاين
في مواجهه التغير المناخي ونحن نخسر
ارتفاع درجات الحراره حول العالم مستمر
والخطر كبير الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراعات
واعمال العنف القت بظلالها على العالم يجب
ان لا نركز فقط على حل الصراعات وننسى
مشكله المناخ لان المناخ يمثل تحديا كبيرا
لنا الفوضى المناخيه هي السبب الرئيس في
الصراعات العالميه الحرب على البيئه
انتهاك خطير لحقوق الانسان هناك تحذيرات
علميه من حقيقه ارتفاع درجات الحراره ما
يعني اننا نقترب من نقطه لا عوده
تقرير كشف ان خمسه دول فقط هي اليابان
وايطاليا وهولندا والنرويج والسويد زاد
التعادتها بالتمويل منذ عام 20 21 قال
رئيس كوب 26 اللوك شارما الذي كلف باعداد
التقرير ان هناك حاجه الى التريليونات
الدولارات بشكل عام
لترد الحكومه الكنديه بانها ضاعفت تمويلها
الدوليه للمناخ الى 5.3 مليار دولار خلال
فتره خمس سنوات بدءا من عام 20 واحد و 20
تقول راشيل سيمون من شبكه العمل المناخيه
في اوروبا ان العالم يراقب والساعه تدق
سنحاسب الحكومات في كوب 27 للتاكد من انها
تسير على المسار الصحيح المال موجود
ولكنها مساله اراده سياسيه فقط